[Music]
so today we cancel a woman named alice
evans who
according to her bio is a lecturer at
king's college london um a faculty
associate at harvard and an author who
writes about issues related to gender
equality and the patriarchy that's
probably more information than you ever
needed to know about somebody called
alice evans but you never know what
you'll learn on this show so the reason
we're talking about her today is that
she recently wrote a blog post which she
shared on twitter titled smash the
fraternity
and in the post she complains that men
have an advantage in the corporate world
because of the fraternal bonds formed
through
sports banter she says smoke breaks and
in the men's restroom
now if you're a man hearing this already
you're probably confused because
you probably don't take smoke breaks and
you've never held a conversation with
another person in any restroom in your
life
and i'm just as confounded as you but
we'll get back to that in a moment first
let's hear from alice let's let her make
her case
she says quote male bosses in male
dominated workplaces consistently fail
to recognize and elevate female talent
rewards and promotions go to those who
put in long hours men can take advantage
of this system because they're
emancipated by women who continue to
shoulder the burden of social
reproduction at home thus the
contemporary system of employment is
predicated on the domestic gender
division of labor entrenching their
first mover advantage the male
nomenclature tends to disregard women's
expertise and resist family-friendly
reforms so if you really want to level
the playing field it's time to smash the
fraternity
by the way
the word fraternity
doesn't just refer to a group of
drunken hooligans doing keg stands right
fraternity also means friendship bonds
mutual support and respect
what feminist alice wants to do is smash
male friendship
she's noticed that men can get along
with each other can develop bonds of
respect and she wants to destroy that
this comes as no surprise of course
feminists have always been driven almost
exclusively by their desire uh their
jealousy of men and their desire to
become men and the thing that constantly
reminds them
of the fact that they aren't men
is that they're unable to bond with men
the same way that men do with each other
which means that those bonds are the
things that they hate the most
that's why you should never marry a
feminist or date a feminist or spend
more than 45 seconds in a room with a
feminist
she'll make your life miserable in many
ways ways you can't even imagine but
this will be a big point of contention
she will not want you to have male
friend she will resent your ability to
get along with other men given that she
cannot get along with other men or other
women for that matter or anybody
back to alice she says patriarchy has
persisted for thousands of years
um yada yada et cetera skipping ahead
male bonding is part of the story
building trust and respect
homosocial schmoozing
talking about sports and sharing smoke
breaks
so if you ever talk about sports with
another man uh just so you know you're
engaging in homosocial schmoozing
just never call it that when you're
talking to the other guy hey you wanna
do a little homosocial schmoozing
no
um anyway that accounts for over a third
of the gender pay gap at one asian bank
likewise in u.s big oil where women
comprise 38 of entry-level posts but
only 10 percent of executives
now she continues to complain along
these lines listing all of the areas
where men are able to socialize while
excluding women she's especially
concerned with male fraternizing in the
restroom and she includes this cartoon
i'll show you of a woman looking on
dejected as a group of backslapping men
head into the men's room together with a
sign that says corporate boardroom on
the door
alice also shared a message she received
allegedly from a man
going into more detail about all the
gabbing and bonding that we boys do in
the bathroom supposedly here's the
message from a friend that says
with all your thinking about gender and
management i wanted to share this little
anecdote i used to work at a large
organization i happened to work on the
same floor as the organization's vice
president who was also a man sometimes i
run into him in the bathroom and while
we were both using urinals he'd tell me
some new idea he had and often asked me
to take some action on it at some point
to avoid getting new work i started
using bat the bathroom on another floor
but it definitely suggested to me that
with male managers male employees get
more casual contact and potentially more
assignments with opportunities to
succeed even in something as simple as
running into them in the restroom
okay
let's just get one thing out of the way
up front all right
ladies take it from me
as a man who has been a man almost my
entire life
literally 85 of my life i've been a man
um
and i've used hundreds of restrooms all
across these fruited planes
the situation described here is as
imaginary as alice's friend it does not
happen
you do not need to worry about it
men are not bonding in restrooms we
don't even speak in restrooms unless
it's absolutely necessary which it never
is
we don't rest in restrooms we don't take
baths and bathrooms either for that
matter we are business oriented
in that environment we go in we take
care of our business and we leave we
don't discuss that business with anybody
we don't discuss any other business
while conducting that business
mail restrooms are quiet places
except for the sounds of dribbling and
kerplunking which echo through our
chambers otherwise we remain silent and
we we we give each other space
it's an unwritten rule which all men
know
that when confronted with an empty line
of urinals a man must pick one on either
end never one in the middle never one in
the middle
the man who comes in next will pick one
as far from the first man as he can the
next will again maintain that distance
as much as he can you never choose a
urinal directly next to another man
never unless it's an emergency and it
better be a real emergency and you
better be on the verge of your your
bladder rupturing and even then
a decent man would allow his bladder to
rupture in a dignified way a dignified
rupture rather than choose to pee six
inches from another guy these are the
rules they're set in stone maybe not
literal stone but in our hearts and our
souls we as men are born with this
knowledge it's our destiny to follow
these guidelines we all know it
this may be more information than you
ladies need but i'm trying to explain
that men's restrooms are not women's
rooms despite the confusion our culture
has on this topic you know that's not
the case alice seems to think that
because women will take a day trip to
their local restroom and hang out there
for 14 hours pampering themselves
talking and doing god knows what that
men must have the same approach we don't
you'll notice that men never go in
groups to the bathroom like women do
we'll never see a man stand up at a
restaurant and say hey i gotta take a
leak hey bill you want to come with
in fact if bill does also have to go to
the restroom he'll wait for the other
guy to come back and go and leave and
come back before he goes or else he'll
say oh you're going to the bathroom too
well i had to go also you know what i'll
just get in my car and drive to omaha
and use a bathroom there so you go ahead
because men can never be far enough away
from each other in bathrooms that's the
point
now there are some men who violate these
rules the men who treat urinals like
water coolers
not literally
maybe they do actually drink from the
urinal who knows the freaks
but they'll try to spark a small talk
exchange there are men who do this a few
believe it or not there are there are
some men who will will relieve
themselves in a urinal right next to you
even when there are other open ones
available
we normal men always assume those guys
are weirdos and deviants and we judge
them and we hate them
and are justified in feeling that way
they're the exception
the rule is as i have described
now i may be making too much out of this
but i think what we find in this
bathroom issue is a microcosm a symbol
of feminism's great flaw one of its
great flaws anyway and that is that
feminists don't know the first thing
about men
they don't understand us at all they
have no understanding of who men are how
we act why we act the way we are we're
not even that mysterious it's just that
they're that stupid
as far as men having more success in the
corporate world it's certainly not due
to any kind of institutional bias in
favor of men
all of the institutional bias all of it
without a doubt cuts against men
especially white men
but if we have we if we still have
greater success some of that might have
to do with the inherent masculine skill
sets that men tend to possess
i understand this is heresy i mean all
true things are heresy and a culture of
lies but men and women have different
skills and they excel at different
things men generally speaking may tend
to be better suited and more cut out for
some of these jobs
and some of that has to do with
different priorities also for all the
talk about gender pay gaps and
everything the gap if it exists at all
exists because women tend to make
different choices they choose different
career paths they take different routes
in life and that's fine that's good
that's called diversity
one other point
if men are better able to get along
work as a team relate to each other
outside of the restroom i mean
that's not some kind of unfair advantage
it's an advantage yeah but it's not
unfair
we earn that advantage
by being direct with each other
by not taking things too personally
by not getting overly focused on
personal slights not getting involved in
personal feuds and so on
women can tend
a little more towards the dramatic as
evidenced by alice seeing men walking
into the restroom and imagining that
they're hatching some kind of game of
thrones conspiracy while they stand at
the urinals
the slightly more stoic emotionally
removed and coolly practical approach of
a man often works well in business
it can sometimes cause tension and
strain in relationships though and at
home which is why a man needs a woman to
help him become more empathetic more
caring more relational
there's no problem with this dynamic
unless you decide to make it a problem
and alice is the kind of woman who likes
to make problems
but business is about solving problems
not making them
which is why she's a college professor
not a ceo
and it's also why she is today cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content